you know I think the more is basic
ethical principles do unto others you
have them do unto you I mean it's it's
it's pretty basic some pretty big that
that's the hard summary of the command
to love neighbors right yeah I mean
it'sit's we were talking earlier about
how what what we did its vinegar was not
generosity but it did involve care and
did expect reciprocity so in other words
that the real test religious test would
be to do one to someone else as you
would have them do unto you if you never
were going to see them again now that
would be real generosity that would be
the type of moral excellence that I
don't hold myself out as being an
exemplar of what we did do was was was
enter into interactions with people on
that basis where we expected that based
on the character the people we hired
that we would get reciprocity in return
and even that is rare my experience in
the corporate world so it's it's a you
might say an enlightened form of the do
unto others and that's about as close as
i can i can get